bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france tout d'abord est ce
que vous vous attendiez à cette levée
d'immunité
bonjour oui effectivement
compte tenu de la composition des
groupes parlementaires au parlement
européen et le fait que la commission
des affaires juridiques du parlement
européen a eu une n'a pas respecté les
procédures habituelles et il ya eu
énormément d'irrégularités dans la
procédure qui a été suivi ce qui a été
d'ailleurs condamné et dénoncé auprès du
parlement du président du parlement
européen le résultat nous ne serons pas
toutefois il faut préciser qu' il y a
quand même eu plus de 40% des députés
européens qui se sont exprimés ont voté
contre ou se sont abstenus
ce qui est quand même un pourcentage
relativement important donc ces trois
grands groupes
le parti populaire socialiste
renaissance qui avait donné pour
consigne de voter en faveur de cette
levée d'immunité et ils ont quand même
très largement voté en faveur il
totalise 4 117 voix parmi les 700 cinq
députés en tout cas ce que qu'est ce que
ça révèle selon vous ça arrivait là à
mon avis il ya de deux points que je
voudrais quand même soulevé d'une part
le fait que les les ce genre de vote
quoiqu'en quoi qu'on dise et puis comme
prétendent que il s'agit d'une demande
de levée d'immunité parlementaire pour
des pour des faits répréhensibles en
espagne toutefois il s'agit d'une
question éminemment politique
ce qui est quand même extrêmement
dangereux et qui est constitue comme un
maintenant un gros handicap pour le pour
l'europe et le fait qu' il y ait eu
majorité écrasante danser les principaux
groupes du parlement européen a voté en
espagne ça veut dire de les décisions
qui sont prises ne sont pas des
décisions à caractère politique et des
décisions notamment de respect des
libertés fondamentales et de respect des
principes clients qui sont à l'origine
des fondateurs de l'union européenne
mais tout simplement d'intérêt de base
politique et des intérêts des intérêts
purement et simplement de donnant
donnant entre les différentes parties
politiques les différents états l'europe
est devenue un club d'état n'est pas une
europe des citoyens
les trois eurodéputés ont justement
dénoncé la nature politique des
procédures engagées contre vous êtes
vous êtes d'accord avec ça absolument il
ne faut pas oublier que à l'heure
actuelle
au delà ce de d3 europe
un député européen qui viennent qui on
vient de lever l'immunité parlementaire
il y à plus de 3000 victimes de la
répression catalan heure actuelle plus
de 3000 dans plus de 700 maires il y a
des députés des hauts fonctionnaires
il y à des chanteurs des gens tous
genres des gens des milieux de la
culture
si ceux ci on ne peut pas on ne classe
pas comme une répression à caractère
politique et tout ça pour avoir défendu
leur opinion parce qu en espagne
aujourd'hui être indépendantiste catalan
est un délit
condamné par la justice espagnole et
ceci est tout simplement intolérable
parce que non seulement les gens ont le
droit d'avoir des opinions politiques
mais également de pouvoir exercer et
exécuté ces décisions politiques et
c'est ce que ses députés et le président
et ceux qui viennent d'être poursuivi ce
sont des personnes qui n'ont fait
qu'exécuter le mandat pour lequel il
avait été vu une levée d'immunité donc
qui ouvre la voie à un nouvel examen
pour pas la justice belge des demandes
d'extradition
pour karl excuses demandées tony commune
est-ce que cela a des chances d'aboutir
selon vous
et bien c'est as c'est une procédure
encore qui va durer longtemps parce que
dans un premier temps il y à un recours
qui va être fait auprès de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne pour en
raison d'un certain nombre
d'irrégularités notamment sur le fait
que les raisons pour lesquelles on a
demandé l'immunité parlementaire ce sont
des faits à caractère éminemment
politique
une fois la cour de justice de l'union
européenne aura statué sur ces recours
ce n'est qu'à ce moment là que de
nouveau là les procédures d'extradition
vont revenir auprès des tribunaux belges
et nous savons que récemment il y a eu
la cour d'appel de bruxelles qui a
statué sur le cas de l'inde un autre
conseiller dhuys putsch qui est
également exilé à bruxelles et la cour
de d'appel de bruxelles a été très clair
sur cette question
il a refusé l'extradition de ceux de ce
ancien ministre de la culture de la
catalogne pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
pour remise en cause de l'aide sur les
libertés fondamentales qui sont remises
en cause sur le fait de la présomption
d'innocence et sur le fait que l'être le
tribunal suprême espagnol n'est pas le
tribunal compétent pour juger les faits
pour lesquels ils ont été jugés
d'ailleurs vous avez tout à leur donner
l'information de lula au brésil au moins
la justice brésilienne a reconnu cette
incompétence ce que ne fera jamais la
justice espagnole dont les magistrats d
eau d eau
tribunaux espagnols sont truffés de gens
d'extrême droite et des gens issus
directement du franquisme
car l'état et mercy for tunis on manque
de temps et je faisais moi merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes coordinateur de
l'assemblée nationale catalane en france
merci à vous